サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
はい それではよろしくお願いします
今日はちょっと量が多い内容になってますが
で 皆様の期待と私の内容はかなりずれると思います
で それを一応理解した方がいいと思います
一般的には我々は心の弱みというテーマが出てくると
仏教でも何か強い心で生活する方法ないのかって考えるのは普通なんですけど
でもそこでちょっと問題があるなって
私たち一般人が考えるのは
ただ日常生活の中で まあまあバリバリ頑張って活動して生きていて
まあ成功して 仕事も家族もね
うまくいってという程度のお話なんですね
で その日常のことを会社でどうしようかとかね
子供が言うこと聞かないどうしようかという程度のアドバイスというのはね
まあ誰にでもできますよ
あまりカウンセラーじゃなくても
おばあちゃんたちに聞けばね
もうみんなすごいこの人間の中で
このおばあちゃまっていうのはね
すごい精神的な力持ってますよ
人を育てるためにはね
ですから  おばあちゃんに聞いてもわかることを私が言ってどうなるんですかね
ですから このまあ 私にしたっても
若い頃いろいろトラブっちゃうとね
どなたかのおばあちゃんがね
しっかり言うんです なんとか
それで落ち着くんですよ
で こうしなさいとね で
そうすればうまくいくんです
で 私には若い頃の結構経験がありましてね
私はもうお寺にいたんだから
自分のおばあちゃまではなくてね
村の誰かね おばあちゃんがね
なんか若いんだからなんかやっちゃうと
すぐなんとかアドバイスするし
落ち込んでるとなんか言ってくれるし
それで物の見事に立ち直りますからね
だから この知識固まっているこのカウンセラーよりは
皆様の周りのおばあちゃまだけいいんですよ
明るく活発で元気で生きていられる程度ならね
ですから ここでこの完成した科学的に心
生命について語ったお釈迦様の教えから
この心について学んでみましょう
だから ちょっとレベルが上がってしまいます
で こちらで言っているのはすべて完成した智慧なんです
皆様に考えるものは何も残ってないし
これから研究するもの何も残ってないんだ
お釈迦様はすべて方法もすべて教えてるんだから
我々にとってはやるだけで十分です
あのインスタントパッケージみたいなもんなんですね
インスタントのご飯買ってきたら
まあチンするだけでプロの味が出ますからね
そういうことで 私たちに残っているのは
このおっしゃっている方法をやるだけなんですね
ですから 皆様 一般的に常識的に期待するものとちょっと違うことをこれから喋ります
それから一応念のために話に入る前に
あの仏教から見れば 我々の心の弱みとか
いろんな精神的な問題とか
あがり症とかね まあいろんなものありますね
答えはそんなの気にするなよと
あまり気にしないでね
どうしよう どうしようとかね
まあ気にしないでいればいいんです
で 気にしないでしっかり自分のやるべきことをやればいいんです
あがり症あったってもいいんじゃないですか
別に自分にいった仕事をちゃんとやれば
口下手っていう言葉もリストにありましたからね
口下手で何が悪いんですかね
喋れなきゃいいんだからね
だからまあ そういうこの
例えば対人恐怖症とかあるでしょ
一人でいればいいんですよ
一人で勉強したり 研究したり
いろんなものを開発したりすればいいでしょうに
だからそんなに大げさに見る必要ないんです
そんなもんやという感じで
明るければもう終わりです
だからおばあちゃんがしっかりやりなさい
それだけです だからいろいろ言い訳して仕事をサボることが情けない
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この一般人に対するアイデアは
一般のおばあちゃまに聞いたっても同じ言葉ですよ
そんなこと言って あんた勉強サボって情けないやと言われると
なんとなくやる気が出てくるんです
はい その程度です 講演終わりですかね
え？本当はそれで講演は終わりです
はい それからお釈迦様の世界に入ります
はい しっかりこの弱みというものを認めましょう
理解しましょう エゴが認める弱み
現実的な弱みを認める
だからこれ 2つなんです
エゴが認める弱みと認めるっていうのは
あっ 弱みがあるんだとかいうとこ程度なんです
現実的に本当の弱みは何なのかと
2種類なんです 弱みは共通
認める立場が違う すべての生命にある心の弱みっていうのは同じもんなんです
私に特別な弱みがあるというわけじゃないんです
皆様にある弱みも私にもあります
総理大臣にもあります
天皇陛下にもあります
生命なら誰にでも同じなんです
しかし この自分の弱みを見る
この立場が違うんです
この私が私の弱みを見る角度によって
あの人と違いますよと見えるだけ
心の弱みは皆に共通なのです
自分のエゴから発見すると
他人と差があるのだと感じるんです
この我々にはエゴがあるんですね
エゴがあって エゴで人々を見るんですね
人々を見ると あっ 私はこの人と違ってます
私はこの人と違ってますと発見するんです
この人はすごい冗談を言うのは上手ですねとかね
私にしたら全然冗談を言えないんで
人を笑わせることできないんだと
それで一つ弱みの発見
それである人があんまり人が冗談を言ったってうるさいと思う人かもしれません
その人は冗談上手な人を見ても
私にその能力がないねとか悩まないんですよ
まあ例えば他の例で見たらね
まあある人はすっごく早く活動して
もう何でもさっさと早く片付いて終わっちゃうんですね
そこで私が自分のエゴで見ると
ああ 俺ってダメですね
もう何でもうのろのろのろのろ
何やったってうまくいかないんだとか
これ私の弱みやと発見するんです
そういうふうに私たちはエゴで人々を見て
自分の弱みを発見する
エゴが人によって違う働きするんだから
一人一人が違う違う弱みを発見するんです
それで もう私特有の弱みがあるんだそうと思ってるんだけど
それは違います それはエゴが発見する弱みなんです
本当はすべての生命の心の弱みが同じものなんです
科学的にいうと生命だから
例えば科学的に見たらみんな人間だから
みんな心を持ってるんだから
同じ心を持ってるならば
弱みあるならば 誰にだって同じ弱みがあります
魚といえば泳げるんですね
歩けないんですね すべての魚は歩けないんです
それだけの話 だから弱み 2種類あるということをここで我々は理解します
私は人と違ってまるまるだと思うんですね
それはエゴなんです または誰だってそうでしょうと正当化する
あるいはこの私はね こういうものだと自分の弱みを認めるか
あるいはある人々はみんなそうでしょうと言って
自分の弱みを正当化 どちらかなんですね
真理として見るならば改善できます
真理というのは お釈迦様がおっしゃった心の科学から物事を見るならば
誰にでも自分の弱みを改善することはできます
例えば 私は自分のエゴである人を見る
その人はすごい上手に歌える
ああ 私もそういう風に歌いたいなと思ったというのはありえない話でしょ
肉体声帯が現れているんだから
そういう音を出せる声帯を持っている人もいるし
音を出せない声帯を持っている人もいるし
私も低い声で喋りたいんですよ
私の声帯はもう高い声質が出さないんですね
これで私は落ち込んでどうするんですかね
だからエゴで見る弱みは放っておきなさいと
真理 心理学的に見て その弱みを見るならば
それは改善できます 自分のエゴが自分勝手に弱みを発見する
自分のエゴだから 自分勝手に弱みを発見するんです
本当に別な弱みもあるかもしれません
それは比較して発見しないんです
例えば エゴで私の心にあるすべての弱みを発見できるかというと
できないんです エゴだから
その時その時何か発見するだけ
世界社会が自分の弱みを勝手に判断する
次の問題 人々がごちゃごちゃ言うんですよ
それはお母さんから始まるんですよ
お母さんから始めて 世界
学校の先生からもう社会はみんな我々に私のことを判断するんですね
あんた性格荒っぽいとかね
あんた落ち着きがないとか
あんた仕事を真面目にやらないとかね
あんたやる気がないでしょとかね
そうやって社会が私たちにレッテルを貼ってくるんですね
それも心の弱みなんですね
わがまま その場合 問題をわがままだと家族の判断を受ける人は
会社で存在感 存在 存在感がないと言われるかもしれません
ということは 家ではまあ胸張っていい加減でわがまま生活をすると
家族はあんたわがまま
やりすぎと非難される
しかし 会社に行ったらすごくネズミのように控えめで
なんかもう隠れて生活する
そうすると会社から見ればなんか存在感
存在感もない なんか惨めな性格
家に帰ったら狂暴 だからどちらが正しいか分からないでしょ
社会が勝手に判断する
会社の人々は この人は今
会社でこんな風に控えめでいるんだけど
家に帰ったらすごいよとは言ってくれないんですね
だって知らないんだから
だからそこはよく面白いんですよ
みんな だから私のことをみんないろんな判断しているんですね
私はよく聞いたら心なんか合ってないねとか
いろんなことを言うんですよ
言っても本当はそれから私から見れば合ってない
外れ それはできないんです
例えば 私はある人にあなたすごい明るいねと言われたっても
その人は別な別なところでどんな態度を取るかわからないでしょ
家族は優しいと思う人が冷たいと友人に言われることもありますね
だから家族の判断ではなくて
社会の判断 家族すべてまとめて
自分以外の人間の判断もそんな程度なんです
だから性格判断とかなんだか当たらないんですよ
みんな自分の角度から見た判断するだけ
自分が自分の心の弱みに様々なラベルを貼る
しかし 正直な場合も見栄を張る場合もある
そこで自己判断してみましょう
自己判断すると 自分が自分の弱みに何かラベルを貼るんですね
私はこういうものだと
その例えば私はあんまりこの何といいますか
すぐ飽きてしまう性格だと自分でラベルを貼る
私は飽きっぽい 私は怒りっぽい
私はあがり症とか ご自分の自己判断
この場合の問題は 正直な自己判断か見栄を張っているかなんです
ごまかしているかとかね
例えば嫌な仕事をやらせるなと先に私は飽きっぽい性格だからねとかね
言って逃げることもできますよ
だから自己自己判断しても当てにならんんですよ
正直に自己判断しても
エゴがやったものだからすべてわかってない
あるいは見栄張って 時々私なんかはそんなもうそう簡単には落ち込みませんよという人いるでしょ
で 本当かな？ね 本当ですかね
それはわかりません だから結局自己判断も当てにならない
他人も勝手にラベルを貼る
それで世間様も私に対していろんな勝手にラベルを持ってきて貼っちゃうんですね
その人のエゴがエゴに見えた判断なんですね
自分がそうじゃないんですね
芸能人 タレントさんたちは自分のイメージなんかというものは売りは売ってますけど
でもこれは私のキャラとか私のイメージだとかね
あれは商売目的で 本当はそういう人々
そのキャラじゃないんです
家ではそうじゃないんです
漫才師は家で漫才しませんね
普通なんです だから この
それは別として 他人様が私たちに様々なラベルを貼る
私に対しても同じことですよ
この間 ある人から手紙が来て
この手紙でお金くださいという手紙ばっかりしか他の手紙をもらわない
私は 日本の皆様方はいろいろ瞑想のことやらいろいろ手紙書いたりするんだけど
スリランカの自分の国に人が手紙をくれたら
私は開ける前に金額まで知ってるんです
そこであれはお金とノートパソコンちょうだいと
で そこでこの紙は普通のノートから破った紙に書いてあったんですね
紙を折るところに 何ですか
すごい質素な文章だったんですね
と 私がそっちを怒ることがないようにと
そこでほぼ 3週間ぐらいスリランカにいましたけど
一度も誰とも怒ってないんです
で 猫たち犬たちが野良犬たちと猫でたくさん来て
私の部屋でハッチャミッチャもうするんです
汚すはもうきりがない
もうソファをグリグリやっちゃうわ
怒りません で せいぜいやったのは何匹か猫たちが
もう私は本なんか飲んでると
体の中に衣の中に入って寝ようとする
それ取って外へ出す 外へ出したらまた来て中に入るちゃんです
また取って外へ出す そんな程度なの
だからもうその人が金も欲しいんだけど
私はすごく怒って もう態度が悪いと思ってるんです
その人を貼ったラベルは私は気にしなかったんで
別にお金送ったんです
手紙を開けて その場で銀行に行ってお金を送金して
もうあれ 買う時間が時間がなかったんです
それで私はみんなに言ってるんです
私からお金くれ お金くれっていうことをもうこれからやめてくださいと
私はものすごいお寺に一般人集まって修行する建物を作っていて
もうだから全部もう金
それに使わなくちゃいけないんだと
で 完成するまではお金は持ってないんだと
だからみんなにただ遊ぶためにお金配ってもね
というふうに言ってるのに
さらにエスカレートして金要求するんです
まあしかし そういう人々は私に対して
そういうすごい怒りっぽいとかね
ラベル貼ってるんです
社会が貼るラベルはあんまり合わない
皆様にもそうですよ だから初めに言った言葉
あまり気にすんなよと
人があんたね 強情ですね
うん まあそうでしょうね
そうかもねとかね あんまり気にしない方がいいんですね
なぜかというと まあ自分の性格を何か見てね
強情やと思ったかも でもそれは合ってない
もしかすると私はこの理解しやすく喋るというか
厳しく喋るんです 人々のやっているおかしいことをなんか厳しくこんなことをやって
何だこれはとか言うんだよね
それは怒っているように感じるかも
私はそれ 頭に残るようにやっている工夫だけなんです
ちょっと大胆に ちょっとプライドを傷つくように言った方が
この人は覚えておくでしょうと言った言葉はとかね
はい 正直な気持ち いじめる気持ちも希望的な判断もあります
時々正直で 例えば両親とかね
あんたね 本当に怒りっぽいだからね
これやめなさいよと その場合はお母さんが正直なんですね
あんたもう仕事をしないで怠けて
それ困りますよと しっかり社会に出て頑張りなさいよと
それは母親 そういう場合は正直
それで我々の友達やら会社の同僚とかは
いじめる目的で自分が何者か何者かと言われるかも
ああ あの人はね あんまり当てにならない
まあ責任はもうあんまり真剣に考えない人やとかね
自分にもラベルを貼るんですね
それはもしかすると自分をいじめる目的があるかもしれません
あるいは希望的な 気持ちで判断する場合ありますね
我々 これよく子供にやるでしょ
ああ しっかり頑張ってる
すごい上手ですねとかね
私もやります それは それ希望ですね
時々子供たち あんたその気になったらすごい勉強できますね
頭がいいですよと言うんです
その人は勉強何もしないんですね
点数すごい低いんですね
なのにすごく頭いい人やと何か何か原因見つけて
すごいことやったって
あんた頭いいよと言っちゃうんですね
その時は私は子供に対して希望を抱えて
そこで正確判断するんですね
そういうことは誰にだってあることですね
はい 次のテーマ だからそうやって当てにならない弱みが大量にあります
自分自己判断して エゴで判断して
社会が社会のエゴで判断した
この弱みっていうのは
もういい加減で中途半端で様々で一貫しないし
というわけで この弱みを克服するのというはてななんです
そんなにそんな話に乗るんですかと
エゴの話は真面目に受け取る必要はありません
う その理由それから書きます
主観的な判断 診断 この診断は曖昧で一定しないんですね
もうわかるでしょう 一概に悪いとも言えない
だからといって悪いとも言えない
誰かが私に怒りっぽいと言ったならば
私はそれちょっと考えた方がいいんです
これは間違った判断かもしれませんだけど
間違った判断するためにも
私から何かデータが入ったでしょ
だからそこはちょっと考えても構いません
心の弱みがあるからうまく生きている場合もあります
これもよく気をつけてください
弱みがあるおかげでうまく生きていられるということもあります
あるコメディアンが言った話なんですけど
自分が全くも落ちつきないんだと
不安でたまらないんだと
いつでも 恐怖感と不安で
それでこの心が落ち着かないんだから
ハチャメチャハチャメチャいろんなことを言う
言って人を笑わせちゃう
そこで一時的になんとなくうまくいく
それで学校の時からもそんなことやっちゃったんだから
そのままコメディアンになっちゃって
結構儲かったんです だから
その人の 今私が思っているコメディアンが心にすごい弱みを持っていたんです
その弱みを克服してないんです
弱みなくなったら冗談言えなくなっちゃうんだからね
だから 自分の心にすごい不安やら恐怖感があるんだから
そこをなんとか慰めるために
ありてもしないいろんなことを組み立てて言う
それがよく受ける それで本人がそれで金儲けて豊かに生きてる
だからその人からその弱みを取り上げたらどうなるんですかね
全く冗談言えなくなっちゃうでしょ
だから弱みが うまくいく場合もありますね
例えば 目の障害で目が見えなく生まれる人々は
その弱みを生かしてミュージシャンになるでしょ
だって 視覚に使う神経細胞も聴覚に使う
だから目が見える人よりはすごい上手に演奏できる
楽譜読めませんだからね
頭に入れなくちゃいかんでしょ
もし目が見えないミュージシャンに突然目が見えるようになったらどうする？演奏できなくなっちゃうんです
あるいはまた目隠ししなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで 弱みがあってよかったなっていうこともあります
自分と他人に迷惑になっている弱みに対して
適切に考えてみた方が良いのです
そこですべての弱みじゃなくて
この弱みが迷惑になる
自分にも迷惑 うまくいかない
他人にも迷惑 そういう弱みは
まあ一応考え直しましょう
だから すべての弱みなくさなくてもいいんです
ちょっとハンディになった
迷惑 邪魔になる 迷惑 間違ったハンディになっている弱み
邪魔になっている弱みをなんとか改良しようと頑張った方がいいんじゃない？比較するから見えてくる
そこでなんで弱みを見るんかというと
比較するんですね 他人と比較すると口下手
あがり症 これ内気というんですか
で 見栄っ張りなどを発見するんですね
これ 他人と比較するからでしょ
じゃあ一人でいると見栄っ張りと言える
一人で口下手と言える？言えない
だから何ですかね これは
他人と比較するからなんです
特に私はこれかわいそうだからいうことで
子供が生まれたら何か障害
何か持っている その場合は母親は派手に悩むんです
私はそれはいらないと
重度の障害を持っていたっても気にするなよと
これは他の子供たちと比較するんだから
あなた精神的にものすごく落ち込んでいるんだと
だからそこを忘れて これが私が産んだ子供
私が育てますと見たら
何のことなく普通に幸せで生活できます
普通と言ったっても 比較しちゃうと普通じゃないんですね
だから比較しなきゃいいでしょうに
重度の障害を持っている子供が 18歳になりました
それでもご飯食べさせなくちゃいけない
何か車椅子でどこかへ行く場合は持っていかなくちゃいけないかもしれません
それでどうってことない
毎日のことだから しかし
他の 18歳の子供たちを見て
羨ましいなと思っちゃうと
ものすごい苦しくなっちゃうんです
なんで私はこうなっているのかと
なんでうちの子はこんな不幸に不幸になったのかと
だから比較しなきゃいいという話です
いたって簡単です 他人と比較しないなら気づきませんね
一つのグループで悲観的だと思う人が
別なグループに入ると楽観的だと言われることもあります
これ 社会の比較ですね
ある仲間でいると あんた悲観主義やと
同じ人が別なとこって
あんた楽観的やと言われるんだからね
これって比較の問題 一体私は何者かとわからなくなっちゃうでしょ
その場合は 自分のエゴと他人のエゴを比較して悩むんです
我々は自分のエゴと人のエゴを比較するんです
これで悩むんです 仏教的にはエゴって錯覚だと言っているんです
これとんでもない鬼だと
お化けやと 獣やと エゴっていう気持ちが
だからこの獣同士で もののけ同士で
でぶつかることでしょう
そういうふうに物事を見ると
自分の心の弱みは別のアプローチが必要であるとわかると思います
それから対策を説明していきます
対策1 制御する 自分に迷惑
他人に迷惑 失敗ばかりをするなどの結果がある
弱みを制御した方が良いのです
消すっていうことはちょっと無理だと思いますよ
ちょっと制御する 例えばしょっちゅう怒る
ちょっとしょっちゅう怒らないように
1 日 400回怒ったならば
やっぱり 200回ぐらいにしますとかね
制御していくんです それで制御がうまくいくんです
その場合はすべての弱みじゃないんです
迷惑になるように 失敗の結果になるように
それだけ 自分と他人の診断なので
制御する方法も各自でわかっているんです
この例えば怒りっぽいなと自分で自己判断したならば
制御する方法も自分でわかっているはずなんです
私に聞かないでください
カウンセラーに聞かないでください
それで失敗するんです
それで私が皆様に言いたいのは
ご自分で自己判断したならば
その自己判断した結果が悪い結果を出しているならば
そのところだけ直しましょう
直すんじゃなくて制御する
その方法は自分で知っている
人に聞く必要はないんです
こうだから私はこうやっているんだよと知っているんです
それはほんのちょっとのところを覚えておいてください
制御なので 完全に克服する必要はありません
対策に巧みに使用する
周りが落ち込んでいるとき
皆に勇気を与えて活気にさせることができる
それは楽観主義者です
楽観的な人ですね これ書いてないな
忘れちゃった 恐れを知らず
大胆なことをやろうとする人々にアドバイスをしてあげることは
悲観的な人にできる 自分が悲観的だと
これ巧みに使えます 特に人々は何か量知らず
もう程度知らず 大胆なことをやろうとするでしょ
そちらに悲観主義な人を割り込んできてね
ダラダラ食べるとあれが落ち着くでしょ
それであなたのおかげで助かりましたという結果になるでしょ
やる気がなく落ち込んでどうしようかというと
楽観的な人が入ってこんできて
何やってんだ これくて
頑張りましょうよと 大したことないよと言ってくれると
うまくいってるでしょうに
だから悲観主義な人にも
楽観主義の人にも活動する場があるんです
要するに 自分の弱みを生かす
これ巧みに使用しましょう
台風のように言葉を使う人々の話を聞いて理解して対策を練ることが口下手にできるんです
口下手人はしゃべれないでしょ
じーっと話を聞いちゃうといいんじゃない
この人はこう意見 この人はこう意見
この人はこう そこで最後にほんのわずかな言葉でこうした方がいいんじゃない
口下手がたくさんしゃべれませんしね
だからせっかく喋ったんだからみんな聞くんです
だからギャーギャーとしゃべる人の話
誰も聞いてないんです
無駄な努力なんです たまにしゃべる人の話はみんな聞くんです
だから口下手も巧みに使えばものすごい役に立ちます
人見知りなら一人で勉強したり
研究したり ものを開発したり
作品を作ったりすることができるでしょ
どこかに隠れて役に立ちますよ
あがり症 緊張する性格の人は
何をする時でもしっかりと準備をする
稽古をする 備えるとかなどのなど
できますよ だから大丈夫です
自分がすごい緊張したら何もできないって
だからちょっと稽古して
訓練して 準備して 備えて出れば
他の人よりうまくいくんです
だから私はコメディーの話と同じく
そうやって巧みに使うと
これで幸せになるんです
対策3 避ける 自分の弱みが問題を引き起こす場合です
自分の心の弱みが問題を起こす
その場合はちょっと避けるんです
弱みをあらわになる環境を避けること
こういうこと わかりやすく言えば
すぐ怒る性格 すぐ怒って喧嘩を売る性格
そこでなんか何か何人三人
自分の知り合いのね 三人がなんかかなりなんか喋っている
そうではない そう言ったってもあれやこれやと
さっと避けた方がいいんです
なぜならば そちらに割り込んだら
自分の性格がバーンともう爆発しちゃって
どうなるかわからない
だって怒りっぽくて喧嘩早い性格は悪い性格でしょ
だからその性格がに火がつく環境を避けるんです
ただ 自分が怠け性格であまり頑張りたくない
サボりたい そこで何人かがね
仕事もサボって 勉強もサボって
なんか遊んでいる そちらに行ってはいけません
行っちゃうと自分の性格がものの見苦しい悪い性格が花咲いてダメになっちゃうんですね
それで自分の弱みたくさんありますから
それを見てある場合 避けるという対策もあります
だから この過去弱みにあって
それやってほしいんです
そのような環境にいなくてはいけない時は
自分を控える 例えば 友達4人が何か言い争っているところに
自分が怒りっぽくて喧嘩早い人なんですけど
そちらにいなくちゃいけない羽目になったらどうしようかと
それと怒って喧嘩するね
それはダメです 控えます
控えます 何も言わないことにしますと言って控えるんです
その環境に行かなくちゃいけない場合は
できれば避けた方が安全です
避けることもできない場合は控えましょう
やるべきことがあっても他人にお願いする
その場合は 例えばやるべきこともある
でも自分がそちらに割り込んじゃう
自分の悪い性格が出てきて
悪い結果になる そういう場合です
お願いしますから あんたこれやってくれませんか？他人に頼んで自分が避ける
そういう方法でよろしいんです
対策 4 置き換える 悪い性格をその反対の性格に置き換えることは可能です
これよく理解してほしいポイントなんです
悪い性格 悪い心の弱みがあったら
その弱みの反対に置き換えられます
正反対に置き換えられる
それは面白いんですよ
性格にも弱みにも裏と表があります
いつでもこの仏教は このいわゆる相対的な物事が存在するとおっしゃっているんだから
例えば物事何か長いと言う
言う場合は 頭の中で短いという概念がうろうろしているんです
これって汚いと言った途端
頭の中で綺麗という概念がうろうろしているんです
正反対の概念が あんたうるさいなと言ったところで
静かという概念が頭の中でうろうろしている
そのその概念があの概念を作ったんです
だからいつでも正反対のものは背中合わせているんです
性格もそうです 心の弱みもそうなんです
すべて対照的で 正反対のもののおかげで成り立っているんです
例えば 仏教が皆様に教える慈悲の瞑想は
人々のエゴによって成り立っているんです
人々はエゴイストで わがままで残酷な性格を持っているんです
だからこそ慈悲の実践が成り立つんです
それでエゴイストでなくなったら
慈悲の実践する必要もなくなるんです
怒りっぽい人に優しい人間になることも
欲張りの人に福祉活動する性格を得ることも可能です
正反対です 欲張り 正反対は人々を助けてあげて
協力してあげて 福祉活動をする
初めはあの人はダメというふうに思うでしょ
そうじゃないんです ちょっと繰り返す繰り返したら
逆の性格になります ですから
私たちの悪い性格やら弱みがあったら
その本当に悪い迷惑 それの反対に置き換えることはあります
できます 頑張ってみれば
それにはいくらかアドバイスとかいろいろ必要だと思います
臆病な生き物は簡単に凶暴になります
この生き物を知ってるでしょ？例えば猫でも犬なんか見るとすごい怖くなる猫はいるんですね
それでも犬ってあまり猫と遊びたいだけない
ほとんどの犬たちはね
でも猫がもう大きい動物だから
あっち行けと怖いんですよ
それでも犬が行っていじっちゃうと
いきなり毛が立てて 尾っぽを上げてキャーッと鳴いて攻撃に行くんです
あのでっかい犬をぶん殴るんです
犬が痛いって泣きながら逃げる
だから臆病 動物を見るとよくわかるんで
臆病の動物ほどもう簡単に凶暴になる
例えばライオンとかね
普通凶暴でしょ ほとんどじで寝てるんです
ライオンの群れのそばに人間が歩いていても何のこともないんです
ですから このこの性格と心の弱みは同じものですからね
ちょっとここで言葉がぶっちゃいますけど
置き換えることで正反対の良い性格に置き換えられます
性格 弱みを置き換える場合は
反対の性格を選ぶ方がやりやすいんです
だから 自分にはそうそうもできない反対の性格を選んでください
怒りっぽい人はすべてに優しい人間になってやると
反対を選ぶんです すごいもうあがり症で緊張ばっかしで何もできない
社会に出られない人が社会に出て大物になってやると
大人気者になってやろうではないかと
反対を思った方があの論理
心理的にやりやすいんです
なぜならば この物事は相対的で
裏と表でできてできているんです
明るいと言ったら 頭の中で暗さがあるんです
そういうことなんです
なぜならば その人のエゴがが反対の性格を余計に気にしているからです
そこで怒りっぽい人が怒らないで明るいことがものすごく気になるんです
欲しいなと思っているんです
だから その人の心の裏が結構気にしすぎなんです
例えば 人気者になりたい人があがり症にかかっちゃう
なぜならば みんなに好かれることがあまりにも気にしすぎちゃって
それなりの訓練しないだからできなかったところが上がり症という病気になっちゃったんです
だから 他の性格になるよりは反対になることが可能です
自分の弱みが危険なものであるときは
置き換える対策を使うんです
例えば自分が危険な場合
これはみんな知らないでやっています
性格が悪くて危険な人間いるでしょ？犯罪を起こす
強盗する で そういう人々の場合はこの方法を使っています
例えば 犯罪を起こして刑務所に入れる
特に私は頭に浮かんだのは子供たちなんですね
子供たち犯罪を起こしちゃうと
どこかに入れるでしょ
刑務所ではなくてね あれ
何て言いますか 少年院
少年院に入れたら そちら指導者たちがずっといろんなことを教えるんです
教える場合は かなり治った
子供たちは反対の性格に治っているんです
だから そういう人々はこの法則をわかった方がやりやすいと思います
人殺しした子供がいたならば
一生懸命命を助ける性格に入れ替える
反対の性格に 強盗した子供が盗んだりして少年院に行った子供を
逆に人々にものをあげる
性格に入れ替えられます
私はかなり昔 ある若者がいて
当時私も若かったんですけど
すぐものを盗むんです
ものすごい上手なんです
バレません そこでみんなもうこの奴はなんでも盗むんだからって
この若者でしたけど もう社会からなんか追い出しちゃって
立場もなくて 私はその時も初期でしたから
それは良くないんだと
この人を直さなくちゃいけないんだと
私は何のことなく反対の性格に直してみせたんです
直したんです ほんの１２日２日で
そこでものを盗むことをきれいさっぱりやめて
いつでも人を助けてあげて
ある日 私はこの村のホテルにいたんだけど
で 引き出しにいろいろお金あれ置いて鍵かけて行くんですよ
大学に行く場合は ある日
鍵をかけるのを忘れちゃったんです
お金もそのまま いろんなものをね
もう必要な人は簡単に盗むものはいっぱいあったんです
そこでこの村に行って
その子はね それを見つけて
テープでそちらにちゃんと貼って
誰かがこれ開けたらすぐバレるように
それで証人も何人か 子供たち５ ６人ね
これはもう誰も取らない
お坊さんが鍵を忘れているんだと
かけるのは だからそこをシールしておきましょうと
そこをできて すごい誇らしげに私たちはこういうことをやりましたよと私に言ったんですね
だから私はすごい心の中ではよかったなと
この子供たちが性格が反対の性格に直っている
簡単に盗めるのに 反対のことをしちゃったんです
守ってあげて 未成年犯罪した場合は
指導者たちは反対の性格が身につくようにするので
ジュヴェナイルリハビリテーションというね
まあ英語で言いますけど
なかなか日本語わからなくて出せなかったんですけど
まあ青年たちの問題ですね
青年たちが問題を起こしちゃうと
反対性格をなんとか入れておくと変わるんです
その中で見込みがない人々もいるんです
弱みを言い訳にしてエゴイストで生きようとする
この精神病というラベルを貼るべきな
そういう人々なんです
弱みが生きがいになっている
このお医者さんがなんか精神病だとラベルを貼っている人々いるでしょ
ああいう人は治らないんです
あれが自分のアイデンティティなんです
言って言い訳して良いことはしないわ
社会に迷惑かけるわ 親のせいで私はこうなったのになった 거야と言うわ
カウンセリング 治療を受けたり
瞑想までするが 本心ではありません
私も困っています こういうこういう私はこういう精神病ですけど
瞑想したら治りますか？と
私は治りますと言うんですね
治りません 本心ではありません
自分の生きがいだから
だから欠点は巧みに使うのはいいんですけど
これは生きがいにして
それを表に出して それで撃ち捨てようと思っているんです
そういう人々は本当に精神病にかかるんですね
精神病に喜んでかかるんです
かかって そこをどんどんエスカレートして廃人になってしまうんです
病を治したくはないが
社会に迷惑をかけているんです
病を治したくないんですけど
お医者さんのところに行く
カウンセラーのところに行く
それでいろんなお医者さんを訪ねる
訪ねて どんな治療をしても頭ごなしに却下する
私がアドバイスしたっても
そんなこと言ったってもこうではないかと
また反対のことを言う
昔は私はそれでも丁寧に言った
今は言いません あなたそれに治らないんだからね
私と言えば何でも反対するでしょ
変えてちょうだいと追い出すんです
今は だって私はもう寿命
寿命は短いんだからね
こんな人に構っている場合じゃないんです
はい そういうことで 今どれぐらい時間経ったっけ
一般的な立場からの話が終わります
それから真理 真理 2つ書いたんです
本当のところ ブッダが説く本当のところ
で 同じ問題を見てみましょう
そうするとすごいって態度変わっちゃうんです
弱みがなければ命もないなんです
私はこのタイトルは面白いと思いますけど
心の弱みとは 存在をし続けるエネルギーです
この精神病の人々からよく見られるんですよ
その人々は自分の精神病でみんなに言い訳をして
楽々に生きようとしているのです
仕事もしないで わがままで
人の面倒を見ないで 責任を果たさないで
いい加減でいるために
自分の精神病を出すんですね
そこは悪い例で 我々も同じ心の弱みを持っているんだから
すべての生命はね この心の弱みは
弱みとは存在をし続けるエネルギーです
生命は自分特有の弱みをなくそうとします
それが生きるという戦いになります
例えば魚という生命がいるんですね
魚は水の中にその環境で生きている場合はいろんな弱みがあるんです
それをなくすことで魚が生きていられるんです
人間という生命があるんです
弱みばっかしなんです
それをなくすことが なくそうという努力
闘いが人間の生き方なんです
例えば 他の動物は生きるために必要な知識
経験 すべてプリインストールして生まれるでしょ
ダイノを使わないんだから
人間の場合はもう脳幹原始には一応存在欲はあるんだけど
生きる術は知らない 生まれた人間は歩けないわ
喋れないわ 何もできない
すごい弱い そこで子供が歩けるようになるわ
もう自分で手でご飯を食べれるようになるわ
もう戦ってるんです 学校に行って苦しい思いをしながらいろんなものを勉強するは
あれは弱みがあるからなんです
それで年頃になったらすごく弱みがあるんです
自分が忙しいし 自分のこともろくにできなくなっている
それで結婚するは 弱みがあるから結婚するんです
この弱みを克服するために
そういうことで振り返ってみたら生きていたということでしょ
だから弱みがなかったら命が成り立たない
例えば この肉体にすごい弱みがあります
肉体はすぐすぐ簡単に壊れるんです
弱みです 肉体はこの我々買っている食べ物ほど長い賞味期限を持っていないんです
すぐ壊れる すごい弱いでしょ
だから水飲むは 朝ごはん食べるは
昼ごはん食べるは 晩ごはん食べるはとかね
それで生きてるでしょ
それでご飯食べたいんだけど
3回も朝ごはん食べたら使用期限はすぐ終わっちゃうんです
まだ食べなくちゃいけない
すごい弱い しかし 食べたいんだけど
そう簡単に食物食べ物は手に入らない
だから仕事をしなくちゃいけないわ
勉強しなくちゃいけないわ
いろんなものが出てくるんですね
それで人間という社会が成り立っているんです
人間という生命体の弱みの上で成り立っているんです
なんで我々には政府 政治システムあるんですかね
弱いからでしょ なんで各国に軍隊がいるんですかね
弱いからでしょ だから弱みがなければ命もないってことなんです
生き物 神々 人間などの存在の次元に応じて心の弱みが変わるんです
だから 魚の心の弱みと犬の心の弱みは同じく見えません
そこで人間の心の弱みと餓鬼道の生命の心の闇が
その次元によって変わるんです
ここで神々という生命もいますけど
神々も弱みがあって生きているんです
それは我々の弱みとは違います
そういうことで 一切の生命に心の弱みがあって
その生きている次元に応じて弱みが活動するんです
各個人に生きるという宿題があります
そこで個人でいえば 一人一人に宿題があります
生きるという宿題 それは弱みから成り立っているんです
生きなくてはいけないんです
生かしてくれません 生きるんです
それを忘れちゃうと大きな問題なんです
時々 人々は 何でもお母さんはね
おっぱいあげて 全部面倒見てあげて育てるんだけど
1年間  2 年間は そのまま調子に乗っちゃうんですね
何でもお母さんやるべきやと
それで生きることできなくなっちゃうんです
さっさと独立して 自分で生きることをしなくちゃあかんです
人に頼るんじゃないんです
甘えるんじゃないんです
自分の宿題なんです 生きるということは
宿題という言葉を聞いてみてください
なんで子供に宿題出すんですか？学校で
弱みでしょう 心の その科目をびっしり知ってるんだったら
宿題出したって意味がないでしょうに
字が汚い子供にきれいな字の字を練習する宿題出すんです
数学下手な子供にたくさん数学の宿題出すんです
そういうことで あの 各個人に生きるという宿題があります
それは自分の宿題ですから
自分でやってください
弱みと戦うことなんでことがなくせない
だから 今日のテーマを聞いて
弱みと戦って勝利を得る考えがあったでしょう
忘れてください 勝利がないんで
これは 空腹は肉体の弱みです
空腹病を完治したならば
その命は死ななくてはならないのです
心の弱いも同じです 心の弱みがなくなっちゃうと
命がそこで終了です 必ず戦わなくてはならないが
終焉はない はい 次に うーんと
佐藤哲郎さん 今何時間喋ったっけ？今 2
時間弱です じゃあちょっと休憩入れましょうか
それでは約5分間休憩いたします
はい では始まります この心の弱みということは
この普遍的な すべての生命にあるものですと考えなくちゃあかんです
私とくいうっていうことはやめましょう
それはエゴです 上がり症
内気のような言葉は差別的です
皆さんはわかってないんだけど
差別用語です 他人と比較して考える概念です
エゴで比較すること自体が差別なんです
仏教では 一切の生命に心の弱みがあると理解しなくてはならないのです
一切の生命 だから私たちは軽々くこのラベルを貼っちゃいますけどね
あんたはね すごい飽きっぽい性格ですねとか
そういうのは本当は差別なんです
判断しているんです 自分にはないという態度で
あんた飽きっぽいって言ったら
私は飽きっぽいじゃないっていうことは
脳裏にあるでしょうに
だからそういうのは差別用語
みんなに共通だったら差別じゃないでしょ
鳥って飛べますねって
差別ですかね あれは普通だから
魚って泳げるんですね
とか別に差別じゃないんです
そういうことで あの 生きていきたいという気持ちがある限り
生きていきたいという気持ちがある限り
心が弱くていい 苦楽運です
雨が降る 雷が落ちる 花が散る
乾き 浮き  なんとか春夏秋冬
何でしたっけ？などの現象を表現する言葉を調べましょう
そういう言葉をちょっと調べましょう
良いと悪いと評価はできますが
差別的な単語概念ではありません
今冬ですってな 差別用語じゃないんです
あんたあがり症 それは差別用語です
どうやって？こちらは判断しているんです
エゴで だから差別です
今は冬ですねということは差別用語じゃない
でも自分勝手に冬寒くて嫌だなとかね
判断することはできますけど
あまり差別用語にならないんです
心の弱みが一切の生命の本質です
ですから 心の弱みということを差別用語にならないように気をつけましょう
それは魚が泳げるというような問題で
生命の心が弱いんです
正しく弱みを克服するために
普遍的なアプローチが欠かせません
ですから 私個人の弱みなくす人ではなくて
生命として 生き物として
誰でも持っている同じ弱みをなくすということをしなくちゃいけない
だから仏教は特別あがり症をなくすとかね
口下手を直してあげるとか
そんな欲張りの世界のアドバイスしません
商売繁盛的なアドバイスしません
もっとディープ深く 本質ところから人を直そうとしているんです
はい それから存在をなくすブッダの道
無理をせず 自然法則を発見して納得する
それが方法なんです 無理をしない
見栄を張らない 要するに
偽善的なやり方をやらない
すごく素直で 無理をしないで弱みを発見していくんです
発見して あ こうだからこうなる
こうだからこうなる 科学者らしく発見していくんです
はい これ 項目に入る前に
科学者らしく発見するというのは
こういうこと 例えば 人が何か荷物を持っていく
運んで その人はもう私がいることをあまり気にしないで行ったんだから
荷物ぶつかっちゃった
私の体に それでかなり痛かったとしましょう
私は怒っちゃうんですね
そこであるがままに見えてみるんです
なんで怒ったのかと で
何かぶつけた 痛みが生まれた
痛みが自分があまり好むものじゃない
これで自分が痛みに対してあった
この好みでない痛みは嫌ですという気持ちが人に投影するんですね
あなたのせいだと あなたの不注意のせいだと言って
そこで怒りが生まれているんです
それで私のエゴも絡んでるんですね
ああ なるほど こういう組み立てで怒りが起こると理解すれば十分です
このプロセスを これだからこうなって
これだからこうなる 例えば何かぶつけて痛みが生まれたら
ああ 超気持ちいいということはありえないでしょ
それはありえないんです
痛いんだったら これは気持ち悪いんです
そこで あ 痛いというところでも止まることはできます
例えば 仏教的に慈しみがある人だったら
あ まあ仕方がない その人は荷物は重くてね
もう自分の仕事に集中していたんだからね
私がいることはまあ気づかなかった
まあ仕方がないということもできます
それは訓練次第 そういうふうにできるようになります
だから ただ単にこれだからこうなって
これだからこうなってってわかるだけで
そういうことは 犬の体にも同じくものをぶつけて
犬が痛くなったら 犬も同じ反応するんですね
自分だけじゃないんです
私は何かぶつけて痛かったら相手に怒る
犬の体に何かぶつけたら
犬が牙を見せるね あるいはこうやる
怒りの表現なんです だから
そのように この弱みなんだらかんだらではなくて
この心の普遍的な働きをただ発見していく
そこで直っていきます
一番目のステップは目的を変える
これを覚えておいてください
これ一番大事なポイントなんです
何としてでも生きていきたい
死にたくないでしょ これが弱みの原因なんです
生命は渇愛という衝動で生きています
これは終わりのない戦いで
苦しみの循環です この生きていきたいという気持ちが渇愛という仏教語
タンハ 私は今 最近 存在欲という風に言葉を変えたんですね
これでこの終わりのない苦しみの循環が終わるんです
それで心が弱くなければ生きていられません
生きるとは この弱みを克服する終わりのない戦いなんです
だったら 犯人はどちらにあるんですかね
わかりやすいでしょう
目的にあるんです 生きていきたいという渇愛にあるんです
タンハーにあるんです
存在欲 それにあるんです
存在欲はミミズにもありますね
鳥たちにもあります すべての生命にあります
餓鬼道の餓鬼たちにも
神々にも みんなにあります
それで苦しみの循環で心が弱くなるんです
だから我々は目的変えます
生きていきたいという目的を変えます
どのふうに変えますか？幸福になりたい
生きていきたいではないんです
苦しみを終えたい これから世界が始まるんです
ブッダの真理の世界 本物の世界
人間に これものすごい厳しく言わなくちゃいけないことなんですね
私はすごい怒ると言われるのはそういうわけなんで
これはどうしても覚えてほしい
夢見てもこれは思い出してほしい
目的変えること 生きていきたいという気持ちを忘れましょう
捨てましょう 捨てて幸福になりたい
と思ってほしい なぜならば
生きてきたと思ったっても死にますから
こんなどうでもいいでしょ
生きていきたい気持ちがなくても生きられるんだから
いらんこっちゃ いらないことにエネルギー使っているんです
エネルギー使うところじゃないんで
どうせ生きられます それにこの精神エネルギーを浪費するんじゃないんで
だから幸福になるっていうことをね
目的変える 苦しみを終えたいと
別な言葉に入れ替えます
いつでも私はこれで幸せ
これで楽しい これで幸福と自分に問う
そうすると弱みがすぐ消えますよ
私は何々病気だ 何々症だ
あれやこれやとかね こんなことを言い張って
あんた幸せ？と ちょっと落ち込んでいる
落ち込んでいる私は幸せですか？と自分に聞いたら
落ち込みがなくなるんです
あ もったいない この短い時間
ということになるんです
そこで生きてきたような人は
落ち込みをどんどんどんどん妄想して
妄想して持っていくんです
落ち込んだ原因はほんのわずかなことなんです
ほんの瞬間の出来事なんです
人に何か言葉言われた
ある女性が離婚したんです
その女性が離婚した理由が
あの まあまあ豊かな家族でしたけど
もう旦那さんがなんとかある日怒って
私はお前を食わしてるんではないかと
で 態度取ったんですね
これで態度きついちゃって
気に入らなくなっちゃって
それから悩んで悩んで悩んで悩んで
旦那を恨んで 恨んで 恨んで
まあやがて離婚になっちゃったんです
一言葉 明るく言ったらね
そこで落ち込まないで
あんた食わしてるって
ご飯作ってるのは私でしょうにと
私が食わしてるんだよと
何言うのかと 言い返せばよかったのに
あんた方の命を支えて生かしてあげてるのは女でしょうにって
何言うのかと ずっとカニ持ってきたからといって
なんだこりゃと そういうふうに言い返したならば
心が明るかったらそれできたのに
できなかったんです だから
ほんのわずかなことで我々は落ち込む
それから生きていきたいというエゴが働いちゃって
落ち込みがどんどんどんどんどんどん拡大膨張していくんです
で 不幸になる だから人間だったら幸福になりたいと目的変えましょうよ
そうすると こんなことで不幸せですか？と
そういうふうに考えた方がやりやすいと思います
幸福になりたい 苦しみを終えたい
安穏に達したいと目的をまず変えるんです
これしてもらわなきゃ
幸福の道が閉ざされます
閉じられます  2番目のステップ
現実的に観察する 余計な信仰も要りませんし
宗教も要りませんし 迷信も要りませんし
ただ単にシンプルで現実的に見るんです
毎日の また瞬間の 瞬間瞬間の悩み
苦しみを観察する だから幸福になりたいでしょ
幸福になりたいと思ったのは
苦しみがあるからでしょ
だから苦しみって大げさに見ない
これ 瞬間瞬間の 例えば講演が長くなってくると
皆さんもちょっと苦しいんですね
こんな難しい話をずっと聞いているとね
頭もちょっと苦しくなるんです
瞬間の苦しみ そこをチェックするんですね
それだけ そうすると眠気
眠くならないんです 皆さんはそうじゃなくて
生きていきたいのに この話長く寝る
だから幸福になりたいと思ったならば
こういうことで じゃあ頭がちょっと硬くなっているとかね
じゃあ頭が疲れているとかね
これはあまり気持ちいいものじゃないとか
そこを見るだけ そうするとまたすぐ復活するんです
今の瞬間の苦しみはなぜ生まれたのかと調べて
その原因をなくしてみる
それ  例えば座っていて
話を聞きたいんだけど
眠い これは暖かいところに座ってるんだから眠くなるんだから
じゃあ立って立ってみましょうと
構いません 勇気がないね
それが問題なんです で
私はこのある日 インドを旅行した時
サーラナットところでね
お釈迦様が初転法輪をとか説法をされたところで
お寺があるんですね スリランカの大きなお寺がありましてね
で そちらに行って そこでもうたくさん参拝の人々来るんだからね
スリランカから仏教だからって
ものすごいたくさん来るし
私と一緒に行ったグループもね
まあ行ってそこに入れて座ってもらった
それで法要の時なんですね
午後の ちょっと時間長いんですね
まあ三十分 四十分ぐらいかかりますね
それからみんなで祝福したり
いろいろことがあるんです
そこでインドで出家した子供たちのグループがいたんです
インド人で で このグループも来て
ささっと来て座って お経一部は覚えているし
覚えなかったし みんな一生懸命お経をあげたりする
子供たちにとっては これなかなかもう眠いんですね
そこであのサミたちが何のことなく立ち上がったんです
立ち上がって手を合わせてお経をし続けたんです
私はすごくいい子たちだなと思ったんです
なぜならば 座ってずっとお経をあげたっても
そんなにパーリ語もわからないでしょうし
で 私たちは年寄りだからね
眠気になったら困るしね
だから目張って眠くなったっても頑張らなくちゃいけないし
子供たちにはそれできないからね
でも子供たちはお経は終わりまであげたいんだよ
真剣に それからいろんなお世話しなくちゃいけないこともある
それやりたいんですね
だから 身を胸を張って
しっかり立って立ったっても
あんまり背が高くないんだから
そんなに派手に見えるわけでもないし
立ってお経終わりまであげたんですね
もしかすると足が痛かったかも
あるいは眠気に誘惑誘われたかもわからない
そういうことで この瞬間の苦しみをチェックすると
あ こうだからこうなってるんだからこうしましょう
すぐ答えが出てくる だからその瞬間の苦しみが消えちゃう
例えば電話していると
よく話は聞こえない 何ですかねと言ったら
テレビつけている それで音を消す
そんなようなもんなんですよ
この瞬間瞬間苦しみをなくすっていうことは
大げさなことじゃないんです
本当にすごい心理の立場から見ると
至って簡単です ただチェックする
観察する だから仏教ではそれをサティと呼んで気づきと言うんですね
これがもう命です 例えば言われたことに怒ってしまった
これ例ですね 自分の心にこのように言われて欲しくない
間違っているということは
自分が正しい などの感情が割り込んだんです
こんな風に言われて欲しくない
この人って間違っているとか
感情が割り込んだんですね
これ発見する エゴで主観で聞いたんです
話を聞いたというか 自分のエゴで
自分の主観で 自分の体の中から聞いたんです
ここで冷静に話を聞く
客観的に聞くという戒め示します
あ 怒る 今怒ったんだからね
じゃあそのまま話を聞きますと
冷静に聞きますと じゃあ聞いてやってみますと
で 主観なくしてこんなこと言ってあかんよとか
自分の判断ぶん殴るんじゃなくて
で 聞けばその問題は解決
瞬間の苦しみをなくす訓練で人格が向上します
人格向上っていうのは大胆なプログラムじゃないんです
この今の瞬間の苦しみをなくしましょう
今幸せじゃない 今 今の瞬間
それをなくしちゃう  3番目のこと
ステップ 感情を分ける
感情というのは煩悩です
は基本的に貪瞋痴です
それは仏教用語でなければ覚えにくいんです
感情っていうのはたくさんあるでしょ
たくさんあるんですよ
仏教はすべて 3つに分けているんですね
貪瞋痴と 覚えやすい 仏教でも 1500 と言ってますけどもね
1500 覚えている人はいません
私もいません 私も覚えていません
1510 あると知っていて
そこを全部書いている本は持っている
でも覚えられない だから感情ってたくさんあるんだけど
基本的に貪瞋痴です 渇愛でもあり
存在欲です そこで貪瞋痴にお釈迦様は渇愛という言葉を使っています
渇愛といったら 3つですね
で 私はこの 3つも一言葉に集約しています
存在欲 その方が我々現代人にわかりやすい
存在欲ところから説明いきます
命を支えるために欠かせない煩悩と余計に拡大した煩悩を分けてみる訓練です
だって生きることは存在欲でしょ
だったら生きるためには欠かせない煩悩があるんです
私たちは余計にいらない
拡大した煩悩があるんです
本当に皆様方 悪を犯してひどい不幸になるのは
死後も地獄に落ちるのは
この拡大した煩悩のせいなんです
欠かせない煩悩ではないんです
これ 仏教学者もあまりわかってないんですね
煩悩はなくせませんと偉そうなことを言うんだけど
仏教はわかってないんで
学者の学者ですけど それは精密分析
理解はできないんで 修行してないんだからね
だから私はここで皆様になかなか誰も言わないことなんて
このポイントも 煩悩は 2つに分ける
必要不可欠な煩悩と拡大した余計な煩悩
説明します ご飯を食べたい
それって普通でしょ ご飯食べたい
欲でしょ 生きていきたいからでしょ
生きていきたいんだから
ご飯食べたいと欲が生じる
それが普通です 欠かせないんです
ご飯食べたいと欲がなければ食べられないんです
そうすると死んじゃいますね
だから このご飯食べたいということは
必要不可欠な煩悩です
贅沢な食事を楽しみたいと言ったら拡大していますね
いいレストラン選んで
友達も何人か呼んで もうすごいうるさくて
いろんなことを喋りながら時間かけて食事を楽しむ
それも欲です しかし それ
命に不可欠ですかね 不可欠じゃないでしょ
そこを分けてみましょう
これは欲 それは拡大した欲
これは必要不可欠な怒り
これは拡大した怒り 例えばバナナ食べる場合はどうやって食べるの？皮をむくんですね
皮食べたくない 食べられますよ
皮は健康にいいんです
でも食べたくないでしょ
どうしましょうか それであちら判断
これは嫌 これが欲しい
中身が欲しい 皮は嫌 ゴミ
そこで見てください 嫌ということは怒りなんです
だから皮に対して怒りとわからないね
怒りがあって 中身に対して欲があるんです
でもそんなのはそれで地獄に落ちませんよ
バナナの皮をむいたからといって
それが必要不可欠な命に欠かせないレベルの煩悩なんです
そこでバナナの皮を剥いて
これにチョコレートの液体に入れて
時々砂糖をかけて油で揚げて
もういろんな部品を入れて食べると拡大した欲でしょう
あれで病気になるんです
そこで同じバナナを食べる時でも
あの必要不可欠な煩悩で食べることもできるし
拡大した煩悩で食べることもできます
これ区別してください
あの拡大した煩悩はいきなりやめてくださいとは言いません
もうこの社会ではそれはもうちょっとうまくいかないこともあります
どうでもお腹がすいたんだから
なんとか食べましょうと言ってレストランに行ったっても
そこは拡大煩悩の世界なんですよ
だから我々にとってはそれ避けられないこともあります
そこを区別すると うまく心を穏やかにすることはできます
ちょびっと金もあるし
まあせっかくせっかくということじゃなくて
金もあるんだから じゃあちょっといいレストランに入りましょうよと
そうすると 食器もいいもので
食料もいいもので 料理方法もすごくいいもので
もう環境も美しくて拡大した世界ですけど
自分がそれを知ってるんだから
自分がただお腹がすいてご飯食べたいだけやと
そうすると拡大煩悩は心を汚さない
罪を犯さないんですね
だから拡大煩悩を発見する
それで終わり 拡大煩悩をやめましょうと
バナナのチョコレートのディップしてまた揚げて食べることをやめましょうという必要はないんです
上野に行ったらそういういつでもそのバナナを売ってるんです
で 私は一度も買って食べたことはありません
はい  4番目 無理をしない
この無理をすると偽善になる
仏教の悟りは本物です
私は悟ったそうと言った人はみんな偽善者なんです
なぜならば 悟った人は私が悟ったよと言えません
自我がないんです 悟ったかどうかと一般人が知りたいんだけど
それ知りたければ 仏教の智慧に基づいて質問しなくちゃあかんですね
こういうこういう場合はあなたはどうしますか？と
こういうこういう場合は
あなたどんな答えを持ってますか？というと
その人はそれに答えるんです
それで推測できます この人はもしかすると悟っているでしょうと
だから無理をしないということは大事なポイントなんです
自然の流れで贅沢に暮らせるならば
別です 別に 自然の流れでも結構金もあるし
いい食料をもらっているし
だからね 給料は 100 万だったら
なんで一部屋のアパート
生活するんですかね 別に
それなりのいい家で住めばいいでしょ
別に 拡大世界ですけど
まあそこは自然の流れでそうなっている
それを目指して死に物狂いで鬼のように苦労しない
例えば あの高級外車に乗りたいんだと買いたいんだと思ってハチャメチャ苦労するのはバカバカしい
それは拡大煩悩に命をかけているんです
自分がよく勉強もできちゃって
仕事もよくできちゃって
仕事をしていると どんどんどんどんもう知らない知らないうちに上々上がっちゃって
すごいお金が入ってくる
まあしげたかない高い車でも買っちゃおうと
でなきゃお金が税金に取られるんだよと
それは別に拡大煩悩の中で無理をしないで生きている方法なんですね
会社の社長なのに自転車でっていうのはね
見栄張ってるんですね
そういう人々は新聞写真に載るでしょ？見栄張って
我々の皆様の問題もあります
それは皆様ももうこの死に物狂いで仕事をしているでしょ
仕事のストレスもあるし
トラブルもあるし もう大変でしょ
あれ 拡大煩悩を狙っている方からなんです
仕事で失敗するし 罪まで犯しちゃう
だからこの分別した方がいいんです
欠かせない煩悩と拡大煩悩
うんと欠かせない程度の命を支えるために必要な衣食住約知識能力などを把握している
はい これぐらいあれば生きていられるという
この最小限を把握する必要があるんです
これは在家の方々はやらないんだけど
出家した時点で出家するあの瞬間で
我々にまず教えるのは何だと思う？最小限理解しなさいなんです
悟りなさい なんだらかんだらではないんです
これから比丘として生きているんだから
最小限衣食住薬の理解しなさいと
これはもうプレッサーあります
それは覚えられる 覚えさせるんです
あの出家の最小限は皆様には関係ないんです
私たちには この托鉢で何か食べられるものがほんのちょっとでもあれば十分であると決めるんです
食べるものは 今 托鉢はあまりしませんだけど
托鉢に行ったら もしかするともうちょっと日にち経ったパン 1枚もらったかも
日にちも構いません それでも生きていられますから
1 日は 托鉢に行ったんだけど
バナナ 1本しかもらわなかったと
いいんです それで 何か食べるものをいただいて
それで今日 1 日満足やと思わなくちゃあかん
この最小限をいつでも覚えておかないと
お坊さんとしても成長成功しません
今の問題は 現代お坊さんたちにとっては
だからいいことをやっているんだから
苦労しないんですね 生活は
托鉢に行ったらもう４人分ぐらい食事もらっちゃうんです
無理やりあげるんです
それで次の日は半分もらったら落ち込んじゃうんです
これとんでもないことなんです
だから托鉢に行って ４
人分ぐらい無理やり信者さんがお布施したっても
あの言葉を覚えておかなくちゃいけない
ご飯は一握りだけでも十分やと
余計にもらいましたと
余計にもらったと思ったら
余計に拡大 煩悩が生まれません
まだ瞑想して悟ってないんだから
ご飯に対して欲があるんです
そういうことで この最小限を理解して
皆様も知識ならいくらでもいいやと思ってるでしょ？金ならいくらでもいいやと思ってるでしょ
直行地獄の道です 最小限考えてください
お金ならこれぐらいは欠かせませんと
知識ならこれぐらいの知識はどうしても欠かせませんと
そこを知っておけばいつでも楽しいんです
なぜならば まあ月々 10万程度であればいいんじゃないかな
十分だよと思っている人には
大体 20万ぐらい入ります
これで余計に金入っちゃったという喜びがあるんです
金ならいくらでも構いませんと思う人
20万で喜ぶ 喜ばないんです
その人は 100万円の買い物を考えているんだから
不幸です 例えば義務教育でね
中学卒業すればまあなんとか生きていられますよ
それでみんな中学卒業だけじゃないでしょうに
あの喜びがないんだから
みんな大学出ているんだけど
全く役に立たないね あの知識は
だって私もただ普通の大学出ただけなんですけど
結構仕事をしています
だから このあれ 拡大煩悩のせいなんです
中学卒業したら もう人間として生きられる程度の能力は十分得たんです
それからプラスアルファで加えていきますと
それで喜びを感じる これも学んだ
これも学んだ これでも学んだとかね
そうすると 高校生の勉強はとても楽しくなっちゃうんです
基本的に一緒なのを知っているのに
もっといいことを学んだ
もっといいことを学んだと
大学の勉強もものすごく楽しくなっちゃうんで
その勉強はそれからすごく役に立つんです
それには常に幸福を感じるために
常に満足を感じるためには
人間がこの欠かせない程度知って理解する必要があります
それを知って把握しておけば
ものすごく満足感で 充実感で楽しく生きていられます
それで苦しみを得ることはできるんです
何としてでも生きていきたい気持ちじゃないんだからね
はい 次 もうちょっとレベルアップします
自他 自他の観察 これはものすごい精密科学的なやり方なんです
個という殻を破るための訓練です
個人個というね エゴを破るための訓練なんです
1 叱られたら怒ったということは
自分なんですね 観察する
あ 怒った 私が怒ったと
私が怒ったと思ってはいけません
あ 怒りが生まれたと この人の言葉によって怒りが生まれた
それで自分のことを観察したんですね
次 他人も叱られたら怒るんだと
私だけじゃない 叱られたら犬も怒りますよと
猫も怒りますよ それは他人ですね
他ですね だから自分特有じゃない
これは他の生命もそうなんです
3 条件は同じであるならば
生命は叱られたら怒る
これは自他です これ 変な日本語を使ったのは
このパーリ語をわざわざ直訳したんです
いわゆる普遍的な心理
そこで私たちは自分が怒った経験を生かして
他人のことも観察して
普遍的な心理を発見する
聞きたくない 嫌なものを言われると
生命は怒りますよと 言われたって耳がある場合でしょ
ミミズには耳がないんだからね
ミミズも嫌なことに遭遇すると
脳もないんですよ でもグニャグニャグニャグニャ細胞で怒りを表現しているんです
ですから 生命にはこういう普遍的な法則がありますと
それでコッという気持ちが消えちゃうんですね
それで怒りであろうか
これいつでもいろんなものをジータジタで観察していくんです
例えば 皆様知っているかどうか分かりません
呼吸瞑想ありますよ 呼吸瞑想は普通のサマーディ瞑想で
呼吸瞑想するときに まず自分の呼吸を感じて
感じて 感じて感じていくんですね
それから他人にも当ててみるんですね
どんな生命も吸ったり吐いたり
吸ったり吐いたり 吸ったり吐いたり
そこで肺呼吸 いろいろ呼吸する生命になりますけど
ミミズも呼吸しますけど
それはちょっと人間に見ても見えないんですね
で 皮膚で呼吸しているんだからね
で 虫たちも呼吸してますけど
犬の呼吸みたいな感じで
それ見えませんね でも呼吸はしているんです
呼吸とは 出たり入ったり
出たり入ったりすること
ミミズの皮膚の上でも酸素が入って二酸化炭素が出ていってるんです
だから呼吸瞑想とは まず自分の呼吸でよく経験して
他の生命の呼吸も観察していて
それから生きるものはみんなこういうふうに物質を入れたり出したり
入れたり出したりして命を支えているんだ
だから生きるということは
こうやって物質を入れる出す
入れる出す 入れる出す
それで個が個ということ決め消えちゃうでしょ
あの たくさん瞑想 どんな瞑想でもジータジタっていう３ステップでやるんです
3番目のステップで普遍的な心理を発見して
個は存在しないということになっていくんです
6番目のステップ 善悪の区別
感情の奴隷になって行う行為は悪です
必要不可欠す行為 幸福になる行為
他他の役に立つ行為などは善行為です
あんまり宗教的な意味でもないんですね
感情で 欲で 怒りでやるものはすべて悪です
やはり結果が悪い そうでない必要不可欠なことは悪じゃないんです
幸福になる行為も悪じゃないんですね
人の役に立つ行為も悪じゃないんですね
言われたから 仕方がないから
脅されたから 怖いからなどの言い訳をしない
我々は悪いことをするとき
言い訳するんです だってあんた言ったでしょ
やりなさいと 言い訳じゃない
悪行やりませんと 脅しちゃったと
脅されても悪行をやってはいけないんです
言い訳しない 言い訳しないで
正しいことならやりますと
そこですごい強い人間になれば
これでもう心は強いんです
あなたが言っても言わなくても
私は正しいことをやりますなんです
あなたにいくら脅されても
いくら大金あげると言ったっても
悪いことはしませんと
心の邪魔になっている弱みも
この視野で見る 自分の心で自分に不幸をつかさどる感情はありますね
落ち込みとかね 怒り 嫉妬とかね
不幸になるでしょ 嫉妬が生まれたら
怒りが生まれたら不幸でしょ
そうやって自分の心の中も見てください
善悪 善悪で 例えば怒りがあったら
これ善ですか？悪ですか？悪でしょ
自分が嫉妬で苦しんでいる
この嫉妬は善ですか？悪ですか？と
あ これは悪ですね だったらさっさとやめます
というやり方で心を育てるんです
落ち込んでいる 混乱している
恨みの妄想が流れるとかね
そういう場合はチェックしてください
悪で全て悪はやらないと決めます
正しいことだけやる これは善ではないので悪です
悪行為をしない努力します
だから物の見事に心が直りますよ
こうそこになります ものすごい超人になります
7番目 生命は平等 これから智慧に入ります
ブッダの道っていうのはきれいな順番にやりますよ
私はこの順番で今説明しているんです
今まで言ったのは普通道徳的なところで
性格を直すところ それから智慧に入ります
個として見ると 生命は平等ではありません
覚えておいてください
私は一個人であると思っちゃうと
みんな個人個人で平等ではありません
だから生命は平等っていうのがいい加減な言葉ではない
仏教でいい加減な言葉はありません
生命と一般的に言うが
色受想行識という五つの流れに仮に生命というだけです
こちら流れ五つあるんです
色受想行識という 説明する時間はありません
色って物体 体 受というのは感覚
想っていうのは頭の中でうろうろ回転する概念
行っていうのは衝動 何かやりたいという衝動
識っていうのは認識することです
ものを認識する その五つのが流れるんです
止まらない 概念も流れているでしょう
感覚もずっと生まれては消えて
生まれては消えて流れる
物事を認識することも
いろんなものを認識 耳で目で認識するはするはするは
もう終わりが無く流れる
この五つの流れに仮にラベルを貼るんです
命と 命という実体がないんです
自分のことも他人のことも
様々な色受想行識の流れとして見られるような訓練をします
これは色受想行識 こちらも色受想なんとか識
パーリ語しか覚えられませんだからね
ただ犬見たら ルーパ ヴェーダーナ
サンニャ サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナ
猫見たら ルーパ ヴェーダーナ
人間男見たら ルーパ ヴェーダナ
サンニャ サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナ
女を見たら ルーパ ヴェーダナ
平等でしょ だから色受想行
色受想行識で見ると すべて生命は平等です
犬だ猫だって言っちゃうと平等じゃないんです
個人で見た個人として見たんです
個という気持ちが減ると
心の弱みも消えるんです
この個人という気持ちが減って減って
色受想行識だということに発見して納得したら
もう心が弱くないんです
8番目 自我主観をなくす
すべての生命は平等であると発見できるように
慈悲喜捨の実践を調整する
調整すると書いてあるのは
皆様 慈悲喜捨の実践を知っています
皆様に教えている の瞑想は
日常生活を穏やかで幸福で生きられるためなんです
これの智慧のバージョンになります
智慧のバージョンで慈悲の瞑想した方がいいと思います
それはちょっと調整しなくちゃいけない
要するに 生命たるものはすべて幸福になりたいと思っている
苦しみは嫌と思っているというふうな感じで
いかなる生命であろうとも幸福になりたいと思っている
いかなる生命であろうとも
生きていきたいという気持ちがある
いかなる生命であっても
怒鳴られるのは 叱られるのは嫌がる
そういうふうに生命は平等やとみんな同じやと
仏教では神を拝むことをしませんが
神々も同じだと 犬猫も同じだと
そういうふうに調整してほしい
最初は普通の慈悲の実践になりますが
徐々にレベルを上げていくやり方は
まず普通に慈悲の瞑想をします
私は幸せでありますようにとかね
それからどんどん智慧を働かせてみるんです
私はって何？とかね 親しい生命とは何と
その場合 親しい人々ではなくて
親しい生命が幸せでありますようにと言葉を変えなくちゃいけないんです
それだから 生きとし生けるものはと
何ですかとか すべての生命ですね
そういうふうにちょっと智慧を働かせてみるんです
自と他の差が消えたら完了です
その慈悲の瞑想で自と他が消えちゃうんですね
色受想行識だからね 自分も他人もありっこはないやと
誰だって存在欲で生きているものだから
もう同じこっちゃやと
わかりやすく言えば 海っていうのは地球の様々な川から水が流れているんですね
川に水がある場合は その川の水なんですね
個なんですね 川ごとに水の質が違うんでしょ
で 海に行ったらなんのこっちゃ
全部海水 全部塩 何もわからない
そういう感じで 私は親しい生命と言っちゃうと首をすがりますけど
生きとし生けるものはと言ったら
この海の海水のように見ることが必要なんです
それで個という気持ちが消えちゃうんです
海の水を調べて荒川の水を発見することは不可能ですね
隅田川の水を発見することは不可能です
インドのガンジス川の水を発見することは不可能です
はい これから智慧は発見します
一切の現象は無常苦無我です
何事にもこのアプローチを入れてみる
皆さんは無常苦無我がわかってないんですけど
ちょっとこの場合は意図的に入れてみるんです
これは無理する必要はないんです
この場合で なぜならば
無常苦無我は真理だから
無理をして無常を見なくても
すべて無常なんです 例えば私のことを皆様に聞こえるでしょ
無常だからなんです いろんな音を出してますよ
私は喉から 同じ音じゃないでしょ
それで皆様の耳も あの変化
瞬間瞬間変化する音を認識しては次に行く
認識したら次に行く 認識して消えて
次の認識に行く だから無常を無理するする必要ないんです
無常が現実です 我々はちょっと錯覚で無常ではないと思っているんです
だから どんなものを見ても
まあ無常ですねとか ちょっとアプローチを変えてみる
捏造した概念 知識と真理の区別は
漢字が間違って見えてくる
漢字が間違ってますけど
見えてくる 私たちは知識と言っているのは
捏造した妄想概念なんです
だから知識は本当に妄想だと
数学ももう地理学も何でもかんでも
これって妄想の世界だとわかっていくと
智慧です 智慧現れるためには無常を見るんです
苦だと見るんです 命は苦で成り立っているんだと
苦しみがなければご飯を食べません
苦しみがなければ仕事をしません
苦しみがなければ寝ません
苦しみがなければ起きません
苦しみがなければお風呂に入れません
苦しみがなければ服を着ません
すべて苦しみがやらせているんです
そういうふうに調べてください
智慧が現れます 智慧が現れているのです
心の弱みもなくなっています
それで心の闇がなくなっているんです
で 最後のレッスンに入ります
無執着 すべては無常だと発見すると
執着は間違いで不可能なことであると発見するんです
我々に生きていきたいという執着があったでしょう
初めからはね これは目的変えたんだけど
生きていきたい執着はあったんです
そこで全て無常だったら
何に執着するんですかね
色 受想行識が無常で流れるんだったら
私ってどちらですかね？生きていきたいというのは
どちらのものを生きていきたがっているんですかね
何もなくなっちゃうんです
そこで執着に立場がなくなっちゃう
執着は不可能だとわかるんです
執着が消えたら解脱に達します
もう命ではなくなっちゃうんです
初めのフレーズと同じです
心の弱みがなければ命はない
この場合は心の弱みが消えたんです
命はないんです それは解脱に達するという言葉で表現しているんです
生きていきたいという衝動は完全になくなるので
弱みが根絶しています
執着があるから心は弱いんです
はい  10番目続き 輪廻転生するために執着と心の弱み
煩悩が必要です 輪廻転生したければ心の弱みが必要です
心の弱みと戦って克服したならば
輪廻転生も終えているんです
だから仏教経典では輪廻転生は終わったと
はっきり言っているのはこういうわけなんです
一切の苦しみを乗り越えているんです
もう苦がないんです 心の弱みとの戦いはここで勝利します
輪廻の中で心の弱みと戦いますけど
それは終わりのない戦い
ブッダの道では終了します
この戦い 解脱に達することで終了します
それで完全 やるべきことをやった
なすべきことを成し終えた
で 終了 苦しみは消えた
終わりということで終わるんです
涅槃ということで それで講演も終わりです
ありがとうございます
[拍手]